[Musique]
m
non
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
interprétant une partie du répertoire du
groupe
ce grillage les mécènes et les booster
et le roucan niveau mais nous exécutons
aussi des titres du patrimoine nantais
nikkei vous avez donc un programme
éclectique exactement obligatoire très
variés donc c'est le russe et le
rendez-vous de la masi oka de la biguine
des piquets joker et des rythmes
traditionnels le carnage alors oui bien
évidemment en milieu de soirée donc
étant donné que c'est un face à face
avec deux groupes
donc je rappelle que face à face avec le
groupe sapotille période le gris stade
francisque donc en effet le dit oui ça
c'est la soirée de lundi va exactement
la soirée du lundi gras donc en effet
nous avons des contrats nous avons des
bons sauts très très bien
[Musique]
on
non
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]